stock Atlantis or Stargate Universe
which of the two would be the most ideal
for a series Revival welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
before we get into this video I'd like
to invite you to join our Discord server
with over a hundred people in there
we're already talking about their
favorite science fiction television
shows from Stargate to Battlestar
Galactica and more
join the conversation now by heading to
dsc.gg forward slash Sidetrack or check
the links in the description with
Stargate potentially coming back to our
screens at some point in the future I
thought it would be a fun idea to look
at some of the series that we did have
in the past namely Stargate Universe and
Stargate Atlantis and think about what a
Revival could look like for both of them
the most obvious choice for a Revival at
the moment would most likely be Stargate
Universe because it's the one show that
didn't really get an ending the last
time we saw Stargate Universe the crew
that Destiny had put themselves into
stasis whilst I traveled across the void
of nothingness between the galaxies Eli
was the only one left outside of the
pods and he was there basically trying
to fix the pods
so he could go into stasis as well
the last scene in Stargate Universe we
see Eli looking out at the vast
nothingness
whilst the ship was in FTL
alone
and drifting
[Music]
thank you
so really it makes sense to bring back
Stargate Universe and finish that story
the fact that 10 years has gone by
actually lends to the story as well
because they were put into stasis and
you could say that the distasis chambers
kind of malfunctioned and it just didn't
stop the aging process in terms of story
we could finally find out what that
signal at the end of the universe was
and we could explore the planet Builders
even more now I made a video really
recently about the planet builders on
Stargate Universe and how Mark Fergus
wanted to basically revive Stargate
Universe and continue the story of the
planet builders
would be absolutely fantastic and I
would like to see that explored more I'd
also like to see more of those blue
aliens you know the ones who kidnapped
Chloe kidnapped rush and were chasing
Destiny all throughout the galaxies
because as far as we know those aliens
have been chasing Galaxy for hundreds or
thousands of years trying to get on
board and of course ultimately we want
to see the crew of the destiny return
home maybe they could find a planet that
was powerful enough to establish a
wormhole from there to Destiny and then
bring a power source that can bring the
crew back given them two-way travel kind
of like what they did with Stargate
Atlantis in the second season second or
third season I'm pretty sure it was the
second season let me know in the
comments if I got that one right or not
and there is a potential for the actors
who appeared in Stargate Universe to
reprise their roles as well
Robert Carlisle has already been
approached his agent has been approached
to see if he would be interested in
reprising his role as Nicholas rush and
apparently so is David Blue's agent all
we really need is Louis Ferreira and a
few of the others and then you could
just chalk it up to the rest of them
just died in stasis and the story would
still make sense
I think the potential of Stargate
Universe was so big I've always said
Stargate Universe was way ahead of his
time it was too advanced it was a victim
of its own creativity a lot of shows
nowadays are very much like what
Stargate Universe was trying to be a lot
more gritty or a lot more realistic a
lot more drama based and I appreciated
that but a lot of people didn't and it
kind of didn't get the viewing figures
that he needed
if it was on now however it would
definitely do well
and that's why I've always said it was
way ahead of its time because it it
really does
it really does appear to be like a show
that would be on now except it was on 10
years ago and audiences just weren't
ready for it we just finished watching
Stargate sg1 we just finished watching
Stargate Atlantis and then going into
Stargate Universe it was a massive
change of pace and a lot of people
struggled with it I fully understand why
people did because it was very different
to any other Stargate show we'd ever
watched before
but it was fantastic it was really good
yes it was a little bit slow in the
first season but it was getting better
in the second season the story was
picking up and it the stakes were
getting higher and it was actually
it was actually gripping I was actually
on the edge of my seat half the time
watching season two wondering what the
hell was going to happen and then it all
just came to an end and I along with
loads of other people really really want
a conclusion to Stargate Universe but
what if it wasn't Stargate Universe I
got revived what if it was stuck
Atlantis what storylines could they
potentially go down if they did that
well I made a video recently about the
plan season six that Joseph malozi
tweeted about a year ago now I made that
video a year ago and posted on the
Sidetrack Channel recently
and so many episodes from there they
were absolutely fine however if they
were going to revive the show they're
gonna have to incorporate the 10-year
Gap in between when Atlantis landed in
San Francisco Bay
The Wraith were on their way uh they've
they defeated them and the rest of the
Rave are still in Pegasus but Atlantis
is in the Milky Way and is currently
residing on Earth what happened from
then until now they're gonna have to
incorporate a story and explain what
happened
now I don't think it would be fair on
audiences if they just say oh yeah we
defeated The Wraith 10 years ago we did
all this stuff and now Atlantis is on
Earth and we're going to continue it on
from there I don't think that's really
fair on audiences I think what would be
slightly better would be potentially
after Atlantis leaves the Pegasus Galaxy
because of The Wraith uh with their
infighting and their Civil Wars and
things like that a lot of them go back
into like a hibernation State much like
they were at the beginning of Stargate
Atlantis ten years later we decided we
want to go back to the Pegasus Galaxy to
see what this state of Pegasus is in now
maybe we already have output outposts
out there maybe we're hearing whispers
of The Reawakening maybe there's a new
threat but they could have
almost been a kind of Peace in the
Galaxy for this last decade and then
something happens and that explains why
technology hasn't Advanced as much as
maybe it would if we were in a concert
state of War like as essentially we were
with sg1 where we were constantly at war
with the guarald and then we have the
replicators and then we have the aura
and we had to adapt and we had to
advance our technology so we got the
Asgard core we got all of the ancient
Tech that we found on Atlantis we had so
much technology but if there was a
constant state of like peace
Innovation isn't really going to be
there that much there's not going to be
much of a need to innovate so maybe they
stayed at the same level and that's how
they can basically explain why they're
exactly the same level of Technology as
when we last saw them even though 10
years has passed because it is a pretty
well known fact if you are in a war-like
situation technology is going to advance
much quicker than if you were in peace
time because you have a need for it you
need to advance to get the upper hand on
your enemy that's just how War happens
just look at World War II the Germans
are encrypting all of their
Communications between each other and in
Alan Turing came along and invented the
Enigma machine that paved the way for
computers as we know them today
encryption methods that we use today and
so many more technological advances it
would never have happened had we not
been at War
and I think that's pretty similar to how
you could look at Atlantis and the
Towery being at a state of War
even though I Ruled for that matter
because we're no longer in a state of
War for this last 10 years theoretically
there's not been that much advancement
and that could explain it I would
potentially like to see John Shepard
leaving the Atlantis Expedition so if
they did go back to the Pegasus Galaxy
John Shepherd would be the leader
because it just makes that it just makes
more sense for him to be the leader like
he would he's been the colonel and he's
been the leader of uh the the flagship
team Atlantis for so long that he's he's
gone up the ranks slightly and now he's
like a general or
or whatever the the equivalent is for
whoever's going to be leading the
Atlantis Expedition I know there was
Richard wolsia from the ioa so
potentially we'll have something similar
which means Daniel Jackson could
potentially join and be a civilian
leader that would also be acceptable to
me there are so many possibilities with
Stargate Atlantis but I think there are
more so with Stargate Universe so let me
know in the comment section which show
you would prefer to see revived would
you prefer to see a Revival of Stargate
Universe and have that story continue
would you prefer to have Stargate
Atlantis and have that story continue or
maybe a hybrid of both maybe we get a
conclusion to both and everybody wins
that is the best case scenario but if
you had to choose which one would it be
let me know and if you are new to the
channel make sure you hit like And
subscribe and press the Bell
notification so you don't miss a single
video thank you so much for watching my
name's Matt and I will see you
next time
foreign